certaines sportives ou de loisirs ont dû
rester confiné d'autres à visée
humanitaire et solidaire se sont
mobilisés plus que jamais les
associations de saint quentin en
yvelines sont très nombreuses 3200 et
elles ont dû faire face à cette période
si particulière
pour en parler nous sommes en
communication avec anne charles un
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
responsable du service guichet unique
vie associative de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
donc le secteur associatif est largement
impactés par cette crise on l'a dit que
ce soit par les bénévoles qui ne peuvent
plus forcément se mobiliser les revenus
en baisse des adhérents ou des doom
saint quentin en yvelines les soutiens
avec notamment une plateforme en ligne
comment cela se passe-t-il alors
effectivement on a mis en place un
portail dédié aux associations de saint
quentin en yvelines association en
pointe qui point fr sur ce vote acquis
je porte à you on le veut vraiment site
ressource pour les associations on y
dépose d'appeler à projets des
informations pratiques des appels à
participation notamment effectivement
pendant ce contexte de crise nous avons
mobilisé pour vrai qu'en veille et
surtout que les mesures éducatives et et
les associations et on a relayé
l'information sur le portage la prairie
bea a retrouvé toute conversion vous
avez eu beaucoup de sollicitations
quelles sont leurs inquiétudes
alors leurs inquiétudes elles portent
déjà sur la reprise d'activité et à quel
moment elle vaut par reprendre leurs
activités notamment
il utilise des équipements pour moi
elles vont pouvoir accueillir les
bénévoles comment elles vont pouvoir
accueillir leurs bénéficiaires et
ailleurs c'est de laisser des
inquiétudes aussi financière tour voilà
les renouvellements de vision est ce
qu'il va y avoir des remboursements
ception des recettes et du coup on
envisage deux ans organise le 5 juin
prochain à un webinaire sur toutes ces
questions là pour les aider à la reprise
justement vous parlez de des inquiétudes
financières ils peuvent apprendre et une
baisse des subventions peut-être est-ce
que c'est prévu de les soutenir
en fermant ou les aider peut-être à
trouver d'autres scènes alors oui c'est
vrai que cette inquiétude
audi lieu à l'espace est forte
aujourd'hui je pense qu'elles sont
conscience que les côtes et plus grand
leur soutien et effectivement voir aussi
les aider à trouver des financements
les aider peut-être à lancer des
campagnes de ducros funding sur le
financement participatif des tracts
années 2000 sénat on va essayer de les
accompagner d'autres sources de
financement et puis il ya des
dispositifs qui existent des blancs qui
sont mis en place aussi dans le cadre du
cours alors je le dis en introduction il
ya aussi des associations qui se sont
montrés solidaires sur lesquels on a pu
se reposer pour distribuer des blues par
exemple est ce que saint quentin en
yvelines a participé à aider ces
associations là alors effectivement il
ya des associations qui se sont se sont
mobilisés sur votre peau pour
confectionner des malfrats et rolex et
de relayer l'information sur le site de
l'agglomération sur les réseaux sociaux
sur le réseau tokyo veut faire connaître
pour tout parent oui là on l'a dit le
territoire de ses douze communes de
saint quentin en yvelines contient un
tissu associatif qui est assez dense
elles sont trois mille deux cents qu'est
ce qui explique ce nombre ici pourquoi
pourquoi saint quentin en yvelines a
autant d'associations
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une dynamique
associative
environ 180 associations qui se créent
chaque panier
donc c'est une association tous les deux
jours et uni à saint quentin en yvelines
cette histoire de bill noël clay que les
associations vraiment accompagner la
construction de l'agglomération avec un
tissu associatif qui s'est mobilisé dès
les débuts de l'agglomération et on quel
est le rôle d'un paul comme celui que
vous
ou que vous vous travaillez tout
simplement d'un guichet unique pour
réunir ces associations alors on a
grande mission d'une part la
centralisation des demandes de
subventions qui sont de l'agglomération
on accompagne les associations dans
leurs démarches de demande de
subventions on a un rôle de penne 106
associatif pour travers une base de
données qui répertorie l'ensemble des
associations et un annuaire qui est mis
en ligne et puis l'accompagnement aux
projets en cours de projet la mise en
relation avec les experts et
l'information la complément question le
fonctionnement de l'association
à travers ce portail et puis des rendez
vous comment vous voyez la suite après
cette épidémie maintenant qu'on commence
à se dégonfler petit appétit
honnêtement c'est vrai beaucoup d
associations elles ont un rôle au
quotidien le meyboom en plus pour
contribuer à la résilience du territoire
on voit bien que si les gens se sont
mobilisés ce qu'ils évitent pour se sont
mobilisées pour mener des actions
solidaires notamment à travers des
associations
donc oui elles ont un rôle à jouer et on
les accompagnera elle qu'elle puisse
poursuivre de bonnes conditions lors
leurs actions merci à mme charland
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle vous êtes responsable du
service bosch et unique de la vie
associative de saint quentin en yvelines
merci beaucoup